le racisme en corse la nuit dernière la
villa d'un français d'origine algérienne
a été plastiquée c'est la deuxième fois
que cette maison est visé par un
attentat raciste
un mouvement inquiétant une trentaine
d'attentats de ce type se sont produits
sur l'île depuis le début de l'année
voyez ce reportage d' ahmed tazir et
jean pire est que man une charge de
forte puissance a éventré la villa en
construction
voici la même ville à quelques jours
plus tôt les mesures s de vent étaient
recouverts d'inscriptions racistes la
course 7 course d arabie fort des arbres
d'or nous avions rencontré cet homme
c'est le propriétaire un carreleur
d'origine algérienne trente ans qu'il
vit en corse cette même maison venait de
faire l'objet d'un premier attentat raté
celui là des bouteilles de gaz qu'ils
n'explosent pas mais provoque un
incendie
je vais toucher à quoi que ce soit en
garde rené mais voyez-vous les musclés
de ma vie je comprends pas pourquoi ils
ont fait ça moi ça me choque parce que
je pensais vraiment être intégrés d'eau
en corse je pensais vraiment être le
plus sympa ou partie de décor ce que je
comprends monsieur cherfi a décidé de
quitter définitivement lille plus le 30
attentat raciste depuis janvier ici une
banque marocaine là une pâtisserie
orientale d action revendiquée par un
groupuscule clandestin dans un
communiqué bourré de fautes
d'orthographe
nous sommes en droit de ne pas accepter
ce type de population il est
inadmissible que cette racaille
s'enrichissent sur notre terre une
xénophobie qui sa fille sur le bord des
routes mais pas seulement
bastia le centre-ville ici on se lâche
notamment sur la question du mariage
mixte ses cordes pincées de marseille
320 une malouine
non madame cassez mondiale que des
mariages mythe c'est justement sur l'île
qu'il y en aurait le plus sûr
histoire jean-philippe corse et hourriya
marocaines ont deux enfants l'aîné tient
à nous chanter une vieille comptines
corse n'était en guise au cloud 2